[Music]
but hi everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout happy December everybody
if this is your first time joining us
today so nice to meet you I'm Rachel I
lead customer marketing at posit if it
is your first data science hangout today
I encourage you to say hi in the chat so
we can all welcome you in here
uh to anybody joining for the first time
too The Hangout is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear about what's going on in the world
of data across different Industries so
we're here every Thursday at the same
time same place unless it's a holiday um
but if you're watching this recording on
YouTube later the link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details below as
well we're all dedicated to making this
a welcoming environment for everyone so
we love to hear from everybody no matter
your years of experience titles industry
or languages that you work in it's
totally okay to just listen in here if
you want or maybe you're out on a walk
or on a lunch break or whatever time of
day it is for you but there's always
three ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective too so you can raise your
hand on zoom and I'll keep my eye out
here you can put questions in the zoom
chat and if it's something you want me
to read out loud instead just put a
little star next to it or as us so that
I
know and then lastly we do have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously too and our co-host here in
the background will we'll share
that um just another quick note I forget
to say this sometimes but I love to see
the conversation that happens in the
chat during the hangout it's so cool to
see all the resources that are shared
there so I encourage you to use the chat
during the hangout as well and and share
all that you want there it's fun to read
through it
later um but I'm so excited to be joined
by my co-host today Matt McDonald senior
managing director at c bond raing agency
and Matt I'd love to have you kick it
off with introducing yourself and maybe
sharing a little bit about your role and
something you like to do outside of work
oh okay yeah so uh I need to for uh
business purposes make the following
statement so we'll get through this
quickly so the views and opinions
expressed during this presentation are
mine and do not necessarily reflect the
views or positions of kbra and its
Affiliates so that's what's going on
here all right so thanks so much Rachel
and thanks to everybody for joining
today and um and thanks to pit for
hosting the the data science hangout so
uh my name is Matt McDonald and uh I I
live in Stanford Connecticut with my
wife and and daughters and um I tell
people I'm a statistician when they ask
me what I do and I've been involved in
uh data science for quite some time
coming up on uh 20 years I would
say um I work for coll Bond rating
agency so uh I think we've rebranded
recently so we are now known as just KB
I would say and um so what do KB do so
we provide credit opinions so we're a
financial services company providing
credit opinions in the form of credit
ratings we've been around since
2010 um so we are a post financial
crisis credit rating agency and our
compet competitors are companies like
Moody's S&P and Fitch so these are
companies you may have heard heard of
I've been at kbra since 2015 so I just
surpassed my 8-year anniversary
so I've been here for for quite some
time and when I started here I was um in
charge of model risk management which is
uh uh something that if you're in the
financial uh uh services or if you work
for a bank it might be something that
you're familiar with I don't know how
widely known it is um outside of
financial services but um you know
there's a need because we a lot of these
companies that I've worked for in the
past and that I work for now are are uh
regulated there's a need for for
controls on the models so we have people
who are dedicated not to building the
models but evaluating the model so I
started my career my my career here at
kbra in the model risk management uh
space I sort of created that framework
and rolled it out in the company and now
I'm uh in charge of the quantitative
modeling group so now I'm sort of on the
other side of the fence and I uh I'm in
charge of building the model so I uh run
a small team of data scientists um
econometricians statisticians Financial
modelers um and our job is to uh provide
models to uh credit analysts so these
are models that that these people no
these people that that that are used in
the credit rating
process and um you know that you can
kind of like group them into a small
sort of you can categorize them so a lot
of them are are like uh statistical
models you can think about
classification models CL uh logistic
regression type approach and other ones
are like stress testing models so uh
lots of times we'll be looking at
scenarios that sort of could happen but
are bad and uh plausible and we want to
get a sense of what what would happen to
some Financial portfolio or something
along those lines right so we're looking
to see when things get bad how bad will
things get and how does that translate
into our analysis of the
credit um sometimes we get engaged to
sort of help people sort of develop
these scenarios like what what would an
adverse scenario for interest rates look
like and we get involved in that and
then there's sort of uh you know cats
and dogs type stuff around data analysis
so we'll be drawn in and and uh engaged
to help people you know analyze
sometimes large data sets sometimes not
large data sets I'd say that we're not
really in the huge data space you know
we're kind of dealing with data sets
that uh fit into CSV files that we can
we can look at right so that's kind of
what we're doing those are the types of
models we're doing you know I realized
that in as I was describing this talk uh
you know it was i s I think I might have
said it's about team building and I'm
not really going to talk too much about
team building I mean I I I took you
might see that I'm reading some notes
here so I'm trying to trying to have
some frame structure to what I'm doing
here but you know I
mean as far as team building goes you
know I always follow the the sort of
guidance of like hire people who are
good and are talented and that you like
to spend time with and uh so far I've
been quite lucky so I I have that
largely uh where I am right now so
that's good what about something you
like to do outside of work too oh yeah
yeah yeah so I play guitar and
uh uh actually I haven't picked it up a
whole lot recently but once in a while
I'll do like an open mic type setting
type of a thing so uh that's fun um I
would what's that I said there's lots of
musicians in here oh nice we should
start like a a jam session someday
deposit data science hangout jam session
yeah don't rely on me for singing though
that's not I do it only at a
necessity um so somebody Aon asked what
kind of music do you play oh so I I mean
I'm kind of more of a classic R guy but
it's you know I don't really have the
luxury of playing the music I like to
play it's more of I'm limited to what I
can play so you know three chords are
pretty good singing Talent never stop
Bob Dylan
nice okay one other fun question before
we they're all fun questions but funny
question last week there were a bunch of
people in the chat commenting on their
favorite or worst office jargon like
boil the ocean or oh yeah do you have a
favorite or pet peeve
one no I mean it sort of it's like a bit
ephemeral like I'll hear it and I'll
just sort of shake my head and say like
G but then I I let it go that's one of
the things it's uh survival skill 101
let things go you can't carry them
around I will say that sometimes you'll
hear someone use a noun as a verb so
like when there's a perfectly good verb
out there to be used so someone will say
like we need to solution this problem
and that kind of rubs rubs me the wrong
way a lot there's a word called solve
that would work perfectly fine right
there
so funny well I I just was getting
people going with that in the chat there
but
uh um Matt for some of us that are not
in the financial space or maybe familiar
with credit rating agencies would you be
able to just kind of walk us through an
example project or something that your
team might be building a model for you
don't have to get too into the speci
yeah yeah I mean I can't I I saw a
comment in here about a particular
rating that uh that was sort of issued
by kpr I can't really get into that I
was not in I was not directly involved
with that like one of my models may have
been sort of employed for that but I
that's one of the things that we don't
really we're sort of a step away from
from like that that that ground level so
we'll build a model that's available for
people to use and part of our challenge
is to ensure that people uh understand
its limitations and understand when it
and when and when it should not be used
this type when it should and should not
be used I mean I um we put a lot of
thought into how we get things out into
the world and we're starting to sort of
gel around um around like a Playbook
that we
employ so um you know a I'll give like a
just a theoretical example of like a
model we may build let's say we wanted
to to build a model that would give a
probability of default right a
classification model so you know that
would be like okay we're going to go
collect data on some sort of on
corporates or maybe Banks or something
like that and we'll think about what
types of things might be driving default
right and then we'll sort of perform a
you know a statistical analysis and
we'll build a model and maybe that's
would be like a you know the simplest
simplest thing a logistic regression
model so if you tell me
uh companies some things on their
balance sheet something about their cash
flow and their uh and that type of stuff
then then maybe we could build a model
that would help you figure out if that
that uh that entity will default um I
mean that's really half the battle and
that that's a huge battle because like I
said we're regulated and we have
internal controls who are uh evaluating
our work so we need to really make sure
that like all of our work is repeatable
and transparent and inspectable and we
can explain it and it's well
documented and then you know we have the
expectation that there's evidence-based
so we perform back testing and we
present that um but you know the the
next problem and this is when I say
Playbook um I'm talking about is like
how do we sort of make once that model
is been built how do we allow that model
to be used by people people by real
people who are doing a job and and um
and you know we are I mean Shameless
plug for posit so we use the posit uh
teams platform right so that allows us
to do our work in a common environment
and we uh you know we have uh controls
in place to that help us make things
repeatable we're using git we're using
uh RN if we're if we're building an R
then uh you know we're making sure that
our environments are sort of uh repeat
are we can build them up and then uh you
know we are uh I mean we're not 100%
there but we've been experimenting with
things like vver and plumber for
deploying models via
API that uh are then usable by
people uh you know one of the things
that we we sort of have been really
working on and really focusing on is
like establish ing sort of ourselves I
mean the conundrum that we have is that
we're a small team right and we kind of
sit
between a technology organization we're
building software and um and a uh in
credit analysts who are doing like the
work of credit analysis right so like
the tool kits between those two folks
and between us are like kind of
radically different like I would say the
analysts are largely using Microsoft
Excel for a lot of their their
work the um the technology folks are
using um python mostly for uh like in a
software development context and you
know I'm an advocate of using the right
the right tool for the job so we're
using Python and R in more of a
scripting
context to sort of do our analysis and
build our model so sort of
being able to talk to all of those
different parties has been something
that we've been really working on and
and we've had a lot of success with that
uh with uh you know the tools that we've
chosen in in sort of making breaking
down some of the barriers that we face
can you expand upon that a bit maybe for
some of us who are having who are kind
of in the middle of that right now how
do you break down some of those barriers
between
teams yeah I mean it's like it's a
Balancing Act I would say
between you know reaching out to people
and uh operating on their Turf you know
talking their language but also working
very hard to sort of retain some sort of
uh line line of ownership of things
right so like you know I would say like
when we do deploy an API we've sort of
had some success and done some
experimentation with
you know providing people with some code
PBA code in their Excel spreadsheet to
call our API so that they don't need to
learn really learn a new skill to use
our work and like going the other way
you know some of our projects some of
our models are not really that that sort
of uh that like regression based model
where all I have is a set of data and
I'm going to create a prediction some of
them are really more software type
models they're more complicated these
are like simulation models Monte Carlo
simulations where we're going to that's
a that's a pretty standard in credit
risk modeling like a pretty standard
approach and so like you need to build
software to do that and when we you know
I want to I don't want to build own and
maintain software that's sort of a job
unto itself so we do engage with
technology and that's like when we go
there we we've sort of decided that like
they really don't speak R so much so we
will have to do more python stuff and
switch our mindset of how we're using
python from that idea of like performing
some analysis writing a script that does
a thing into writing like python code
that is um that is integrated in like a
software development type of a project
so like you know I
I I'd say that we've been had a lot of
success with like learning the tools
that are employed by technology and
trying to figure out how we apply those
to our work so
like everybody on the team uh has been
learning git we really are getting very
good at git and we find that git is a
super useful tool not just for like I
said earlier we need all of our work to
be repeatable because we could be sort
of uh engaged by a whole bunch of people
who are asking us to explain what we've
done uh so git is super helpful for that
all of our code is like transparent
inspectable people can see all the
changes that have happened over time um
but also we're using some of the project
management um uh tools that they have so
things like
jira and uh Wiki based documentation
things are we've had a lot of success
with thank you I see um Julia you had a
follow-up question here on the
repeatable work do you want to jump in
sure thanks this is really ex
interesting um so you you were just
touching on how your work needs to be
like replicable and transparent um does
that extend also to your models do your
models need to be
explainable or is it okay to use
blackbox models as long as the process
to derive them has been transparent in
your industry yeah yeah no I think that
um not there's no like regulatory need
or sort of like nothing dictating what
kind of like algorithms we can use to
build our models but I would say we
definitely sort of stay on the side of
simpler uh you know maybe maybe slightly
less performative models uh that are
explainable because it's more of like
not only do I have to explain it to the
credit analyst but like they they
probably need to explain to like you
know a lot of other people how they
arrived at their decision so if we have
a just a absolute black box that doesn't
really work for us although we have like
used some of those uh approaches to help
us like Benchmark our models so you know
when you you know you have kind of like
a matrix of like model performance and
and uh interpretability I would say
would be uh kind of a graph I've seen in
the past and we're kind of like on the
interpretable end of the spectrum but um
you know lots of times we'll ask the
question like what what are we leaving
on the table as far as like model
performance uh when we make that
decision so we'll like employ like a
more blackbox type approach to say like
look if we didn't care if we could
explain this to anybody ever what what
could we achieve and and we kind of use
that as a in our decision ision making
process thank you Andy I see you had a
question a bit earlier do you want to
jump in here sure thanks hi I'm Andy n
is um Brewster and my question was uh
about the uh looking ahead if you're
using you did answer the question
actually you're using some simulation
model versus just data driven um
exploration and I was curious if you're
doing that in r or kind of what's the
stack on that side of the house thanks
yeah um yeah I would say like the we I
mean we we use both Python and R for our
sort of more backward-looking
statistical data driven models and then
um you know those models that are more
like simulation based or or Monte Carlo
type things just simply because we are
you know we're eager to sort of tap into
some of the the good stuff that our
technology team has been building sort
of we are we primarily if we're we're
going to be writing
software aside from like internal R
packages that are we're that are really
like my team is the audience for those
we're we're going to build a package
that's going to be help us do something
um you know we'll use R for that but
like if we're going to be building
software that's going to be
deployed
um across the company then we'll be
looking to python
mostly you know some of the other um
some you know like that's you know we've
been experimenting with deplo like the
very simple and
straightforward you know I think I've
heard the term microservice but I I
probably am misusing it like the idea of
like I have some data and I want to get
a prediction from that data like we've
been working with uh like I said plumber
and and um iner for those types of
things where we can deploy that and
those get deployed to our uh R um posit
connect
server um you know the the software
stuff uh happens mostly As sort of a
collaborative effort between us and our
technology sort of uh folks in Python
but another thing that we've had a lot
of success with um is when we're doing
like more of an analysis or helping
somebody uh sort of maybe we've actually
written a few uh research pieces mostly
internal research pieces in um we've
been using quto quite a bit so quto is a
very very useful tool to create
documents that are sort of very closely
inter
interwoven with uh the underlying data
and um and that's been a super useful
tool and and that kind of gets us out of
the business of
emailing spreadsheets and Word Documents
and that type of stuff like I much much
much prefer the pattern of of publishing
a document we publish it to our connect
server and sharing a link with somebody
and then if I need to update it I can
update it there and there's even some
really nice features that we've we've
seen about like you can have uh the same
code the same quto document generating
uh you know the web page that someone's
looking at and downloading it as a PDF
and the PDFs you know look really nice
so we've had some really good success
there
awesome I see there was a question about
get a bit earlier here let me ask it I
see there's a star there what resources
if any did you use to help your team uh
get on board with using git were you all
pretty familiar with it already or did
anyone on the team start learning from
the ground
up I would say we've been learning from
the ground up and and you know I was
thinking about this recently that um I
must have taken 10 different times like
said okay I'm GNA learn git and I go you
know take a some sort of online course
and sort of learn the
fundamentals and I it never stuck like I
just was like I don't really get this
too much and it wasn't until actually we
were having help from you know the folks
in our technology team on how to set up
our repos what kind of of sort of
um you know
patterns do we use when we
collaborate I recent I just today was
told we were using like a trunk based
approach for for when we do our our
branches and merges so that was kind of
news to me but I I would say like none
of it really stuck until I was put in a
position or I put myself in a position
where like I had to use it and then once
I I mean once we started collaborating
across the team and I I that's when I
really saw the the power of it because
you know I'm from a PL before get I
mean back in my
day it was like you'd have some code and
then you'd if you needed to change it
you just were praying that it didn't
break and if it broke you kind of we're
sitting there like thinking oh boy I
hope I remember what I did so I can undo
it and it's like really liberating to
not have that kind of be carrying around
that mental luggage all the time about
about what have I changed over the last
two hours and and could I could I sort
of recover what I had before so I mean
I'm a huge git Advocate right now like
um there's a really good good paper out
there good enough practices for
scientific Computing I think Jenny
Bryant who's a posit employee is a
co-author of that thing and that's a
really good good uh she also has a uh uh
get for R I think or something like that
or some book like that yeah there's a
lot of love for that resource in the
chat right now too happy get with r
happy get with r yeah that's the one and
that's like you know even nowadays if
I'm doing something and I'm not
collaborating with anyone and I'm in our
studio I'm starting up a new project I
mean I'm clicking that get repa Buton
every time because that's like that's my
safety net so I'd say like I don't have
really I mean we were lucky we had
people in our organization that helped
us get over the hump but um you know the
best way to get familiar with it is use
it so it's kind of a catch 22 I think
there quick question what's your
background view right now are you in New
York right now at the office or yes so I
work in Midtown Manhattan so that's I
have a view of the East River out there
so and so I can see from if I go that
way I can see the 59th Street bridge and
then over there I can see the uh United
Nations
building yor yesterday I should have
came by the office oh yeah yeah did you
see any of the lights I did yeah it was
nice nice yeah I'm walking distance over
to like Sachs and the tree and stuff so
the other day I walked over there it's
really cool cool shoot I should have
checked I was right there yeah I got I
got to meet with Russ who's usually in
the Hangouts too um let's see let me
jump over to oh Michael you had a
question in the chat do you want to jump
in here sure if you're you're talking
about me um yeah hi Michael Thomas I'm
also do a lot of data science work in
the financial services space
particularly in Risk Management so I was
really excited uh to hear from you today
Matt I appreciate it uh I was wondering
if you use uh shiny apps at all to
communicate results of like Monte Carlo
simulations or stress testing and things
like that and how uh that's gone if if
at all uh to presenting those types of
results to to non-technical folks
specifically yeah we do use shiny um you
know one of the one of the things that
like I I get a little bit nervous about
with shiny is like um you know it's such
an amazing tool I would say that we've
kind of limited our use of that to like
more of the model development piece like
so we when we're building a model and we
want to communicate like to like the
users or the model owners or the you
know the subject matter experts the
people who know this stuff like how this
model works if I put in this input what
kind of output what kind of
sensitivities am I seeing um shiny has
been a really great tool for
that you know my concern about shiny is
like if I build something that is like
super awesome which is really accessible
with shiny like you can build really
amazing things you know my concern would
be that like it it you know I don't view
myself as like somebody who writes
production code so if it were to become
part of like a core part of people's
people's day-to-day lives i' get nervous
about like something along the lines of
getting a call at like 11 pm that the
shiny apps down and can you fix it Matt
and I'm the only guy who knows how to
fix it so it's like a bit of a
double-edged sword so we do try to like
really leverage our technology teams
when it comes to building sort of core
core functionality software
functionality that people need so it's
like it's like with great power comes
great responsibility type of a message
I'm saying there but we've had great
success with shiny I think it's a shiny
it's a it's a really great tool but
mostly in the prototyping and sort of
early result stage I would
say
yeah I hear that no thank you sorry do
you hand it over to that team as an API
is that the workflow you were talking
about earlier
um so yeah we would sort of try to if
that model we would either try to I mean
we we haven't really fully executed on
this Vision but we would be looking to
deploy the model as an API and then
allow you know kind of reduce the bar of
of accessibility to people there so that
they could if they wanted to perform
some analysis they could kind of do it
themselves or the other path would be
like you know try to sort of work with
technology to build some sort of
software that would be kind of in our in
our stable of software internally built
software that people are using to get
things done yeah thank you um Alan I see
you had a question want to jump in here
yeah hi um Matt this is a super like
naive question about the industry and
I'm curious about how the work that you
do translates over to what like the
analysts are taking to customers and I'm
assuming that there's something that
differentiates like that's your value
proposition for like our analysis is
better um right because you've got
competitors in the industry and so I
wonder if you can just give some context
to like like what makes what makes a a
report successful to you and to your
customers and how do you um like how do
how does that factor into like how do
you plan an analysis or how do you plan
a model um you can come at that in any
way that that is useful I'm sort of just
wondering how like how does this data
fit into the big picture of what your
customers are are looking for sure
that's I mean that's not that's a good
question so you know the way our
business works is you we have a lot of
different ratings teams so all of those
teams are sort of experts in their field
there's a whole bunch of different types
of things that we're rating so we rate
corporates we rate Banks and then
there's this whole other side of the
fence where it's like people issue debt
that are that's backed by sort of some
sort of cash generating assets so that's
called structured Finance so like
Residential Mortgage back Securities is
a thing out there commercial mortgage
back Securities so that so each one of
those things kind of has its team of of
subject matter experts that are in
charge of like doing the credit analysis
they know all about what dve drives the
credit what could make the credit not
pay you know they know all that stuff so
uh each one of those groups have one or
more that we call them methodologies so
these are public statements to the world
that describe everything that goes into
like it's kind of like the Playbook it's
not it's not as sort of step one two
three like it's not like a recipe book
but if you're if you know the industry
you could pick that thing up and you
would have a sense of like what is how
do we do it how do we what are we
thinking about when we when we and I say
we uh our company
KB doeses ACC credit rating so uh you
know the models we build are generally
like a a component of that right so we
will build you know there's qualitative
quantitative aspects of of the the
process and and our our work flows into
the uh the quantitative piece of that
but it's all it's all part of a broader
thing so you know I would say that KB
differentiates itself with like we have
like I said really strong credit rating
uh experts who who do the work and they
do they do quite extensive writeups on
everything every consideration they have
when they're creating the rating so it's
it's uh hopefully that helps illustrate
a little bit of what's going on there
yeah yeah it does thank you
yeah Matt I remember I'm thinking back
to our conversation at the posit
conference and we were talking a bit
about how you collaborate with business
users or people that primarily use
Excel company and I was wondering if you
could expand a little bit on that and
share how you've been able to I guess
effectively collaborate with business
users
yeah well we we have
um we have experimented a little bit
with like like writing sort of VBA code
that we can share with people that um
would sort of allow them give them
access to in a non-programmatic way sort
of to an API like if I were to give if I
were to publish an the best API in the
world you know I I think there's
probably 80 to 90% of the people who who
I work with just it wouldn't be
particularly helpful for them because uh
they don't know they don't know how to
interact with that um you know there is
quite a bit of
um uh you know it's always a a um a
decision to be made I mean we do we I've
done some work where I I've implemented
my model in Excel and that's that's okay
too you know so I think uh um you know
JD long did the keynote speech at
deposit comp last uh last uh I don't
know when it was recently and uh you
know he he's a big advocate of like you
know being Mindful and empathetic for
people because ultimately people you
know they're just trying to do their job
and they just want to get things done
and uh my job is to try to help them so
it's it's definitely a challenge though
because the what I I do really want to
sort of maintain some sort of back some
sort of um um line between like my work
and their work and you know I don't
really want to become their uh you know
Excel support line type person so that's
kind of a thing I'm uh always trying to
balance I see Tim you had a question a
bit earlier about internal packages but
I see you might have a few so feel free
to pick your favorite question well you
already answered my question about
internal packages and another thing you
mentioned that you were writing some
internal packages um yeah uh the
question I just asked though is are you
with a small team are you using large
language models like chat gbt or things
like that to assist with your code
writing at all yeah so we are um I think
that's in our future and that's
something I'm really eager to to sort of
engage with and have that kind of
assistance with jet GPT uh GitHub
co-pilot is uh I've sort of dabbled with
like at home but like you know we as an
organization uh you know I think there
are some security concerns you know we
don't generally like to we we I mean we
are dealing with sometimes non-public
information so we are very kind of
locked down so oh yeah I work at a law
firm so I feel your pain we we have our
own uh our own version of chat GPT
hosted in Azure that's just for us so
I'm I will tell you it is so much better
at writing roxygen comments for
functions for a package than I ever
could be oh I can't wait we have not we
have not yet engaged with that that
sounds like a an awesome awesome usec
case of that that
technology yeah but we're we're we
haven't done that yet I and you know I I
sit right next to the head of
security um and you know I'm talking to
technology that I do think that like at
some point everybody's going to have
that tool because if you don't then
you're kind of just not performing as
well as your
competitors yeah we're just not there
yet I see Bill had a question a bit
earlier um that was are you seeing more
open source being used in the financial
industry um I mean we're using R and
Python and pretty much our entire uh
entire software internal software
development teams are using python so
yeah we're we're in favor of Open Source
yeah I guess maybe it's also like how
have you seen it change over the past
eight years of being there
too um I'd I mean when I so my company
was formed in 2010 and I I arrived in
like 2015 so it was definitely like a
startup mentality so I would say like uh
at that time
it it was a little bit about get just
get the job done however you need to I'd
say that like we are getting more and
more sort of you know as we grow our
control framework is is maturing and
we're getting more and more controls in
place but that hasn't prevented us from
engaging with open source in any
way uh Julia I see you had a another
question
around like what happens when you're
done with the model do you want to jump
in
here yeah you were talking ear about how
shiny for you is mostly a piloting tool
and also that you've been trying to put
things behind for example
API like you put a very very API app for
a model and my question is mostly what
what is it that actually consumes the
models that you build do you have your
it build some infrastructure around that
or is will there be like a bat job that
gets run like how does your model then
yeah blub out I think I would say that
you know we have not yet like
standardized everything to the point
where like we I can say like we always
do X Y or Z so like you know it's been
it will will sort of incorporate our
models into their into their software
that they're building like I said
sometimes we kind of embed ourselves in
the technology team and and and sort of
put a hat on as a software developer to
write the portion of the code that does
that implements the model um you know
sometimes uh you know
sometimes uh We've implemented our
models with uh worksheet functions and
and they're completely done in Excel so
there's no like real what what I'm
trying to do is to sort of standardize
things to the point like I would love to
be in a position where if I were to
deploy an
API then uh you know everybody in the
company would have access to it without
a
huge huge uh hurdle to
overcome just starting to look at the
chat
here yeah it can be overwhelming to try
and talk at the same time but I'll send
it to you so you can read it after
too um but I did just share in the the
chat we did have a a recent event I'm
losing track of time maybe this was last
week but it was a really helpful machine
learning um workflow that Gordon
Shotwell from our team went through so I
just put it in the chat if anyone wants
to check it out I feel like this
conversation was just reminding me of a
lot of talked about yeah I will say that
like so you know I I I I love the work
that Max cun and uh and Julia have been
doing it with uh you know the Tidy model
suite and when uh Julio started talking
about like vver and model deployment and
model
monitoring it was it was it was really
heartening to see that other people were
thinking about that stuff as well
because that's like you know you could
build the model and you could sort
of uh and your job's not done your job's
like way far from done people you have
to figure out how to get people how to
allow people to use your model and
that's that's a big that's a big uh
tough nut to crack
so how do we get people to use it oh
well so we're like I said we sometimes
we make it work in Excel sometimes we
deploy an API and sometimes we become
software engineers and start making
commits to a git repo I guess I'm
thinking too like about the
communication part of it like how do how
do you work with them to help people see
the value in some of the models or do
they see that
initially yeah i c well I mean I would
love to sort of like solve all of the
problems I currently have and put myself
s in a position to start like generating
more internal business for myself by
convincing people to trust their models
more and and uh and uh um use you know
use them more and more and more but like
you know we we kind of are dealing with
the problem in front of us right now I
would say yeah another question I I saw
just pop into the chat Bill asked in
your organization do you have to justify
or submit for approval to an it or
regulatory
group um I mean yeah I mean we have a we
have a um it's a whole it's a whole
thing right so we need to sort of
describe the project we're making and
then that sort of goes we're we're
proposing and then that and then that
goes into sort of a prioritization ation
decision making type of a thing and then
uh and then I mean it's it's uh not
quite as formalized as other places I've
seen so it's not like I'm filling out
like form form t t95 or anything like
that but there is a I mean we obvious I
mean we're a business right so we
uh we need to work on the things that
are most important to us yeah so
definitely but
you know um I'm I'm I'm sort of lucky
that I've been here for quite some time
I you know a lot of the I'd say that
early on while I was here um a lot of a
lot of what I was doing was was work to
sort of gain people's trust and that's a
super important thing right so um and um
not to Pat myself on the back too hard
but I did it right so people I have
worked hard to make sure that people can
trust me so like you know uh this most
we just recently kicked off a new
project where it's more of that software
development type of a of a lane that
we're getting into and that that one for
a long time I was really sort
of trying to figure out how do I do this
job I don't want to be I'm not a
software developer but I kind of play
one on TV sometimes um how do I do this
job where I you know where I can keep a
low profile and do things
autonomously um and I kind of concluded
that that there are certain things that
you do need to to get in the queue get
in that prioritization sort of uh game
um and uh and that's the best that's
going to be the best outcome because you
know you don't really want to be
creating in an organization like a
shadow it or organization or anything
like that I think that's that it's great
for getting things done but I think down
the line you know we pay a lot of people
who really know a lot about technology
to do that job like I don't want to have
you know another one of those run by the
handful of people I have right that
become really important right so I'd
rather be on their on their Turf are
there questions that you'd like to ask
the group here or things that you'd love
to maybe open up to more of a a
discussion on trying to think back to we
were talking about at at the conference
as well and we
were um I hadn't really contemplated
that I thought you guys were gonna ask
me questions I no I cannot I keep going
on this I just wanted to make sure that
like if there are
certain problems that you're facing that
you're just curious to open up to ask
everybody here that we we give the time
for that as well yeah um no if somebody
has has any good ideas after hearing
like what we're dealing with I mean you
know a lot of the a lot of the sort
of difficulties sort of we've
encountered being in this role between
like the credit rating analysts who are
doing their job they want to rate the
they want to do the credit analysis and
Technology who's also doing their job is
that you know it really opened us up to
it being just people not really
understanding what our role is right so
like we lots of times we really do get
confused with technology like we'll get
a call from I'll get a call from senior
leadership people who are very senior in
the company and said like I need this
thing that does X Y and Z and they're
not describing a model they're not
describing like really anything I I I'm
I do or I'm really good at uh so you
know that sort of establishing like
trying trying to continually Hammer home
like what describe to people what is it
that I what would you say you do here
you know I I that's a that's something
that I I um I've sort of encountered a
lot like that that Clarity and making
sure that people understand that and
then just that idea of like trying to
really because we are we're a smaller
team and you know we do have limited
resources um just establishing those
lines of ownership right and helping
people people without
like you know doing their job is kind of
a a thing that that can be difficult to
so those are things that kind of need to
be managed I would say and that's what a
lot of I wouldn't say I I spent a lot of
time on it but I've spent a lot of time
thinking about it in the past and a lot
of the like a lot of the things we've
done around um you know using the right
tools to to get our our work repeatable
and and this type of thing and being
able to engage with technology ology
sort of on their Turf in certain
instances has has really been
beneficial I see a lot of great
questions uh jumping into the or coming
into the chat here um Laura do you wna
ask your question here sure I'm gonna
stay off camera because I'm a little
under the weather um but uh so my
question is have there ever been
situations where a rating against maybe
a portfolio or a company has come out
against what the check is I'm always
interested in those situations where an
analysis goes against the initial
hypothesis and how organizations handle
that so I wonder if you have some
situations and how you've navigated
those yeah I mean I would say that like
you know we I mean none of our ratings
are like the model spits out the rating
and that's what we go with right so it's
always there's always a a level of human
oversight and human intervention there I
would say I mean obviously with any
model you're going to have some outcome
that somebody who really knows the
domain is going to
say no I don't think that's the deal I
don't think that's what it is but you
know our methodologies sort of really
accommodate for that right like these
are there's always a
qualitative and a quantitative component
and and ultimately like the the way the
process works there's a rating committee
and the the decision is made not by my
model right my model is an input into
that process um um you know part of the
reason why we you know earlier I said we
we we rely you know given the choice
between you know a model whose accuracy
ratio is 1% greater than this other
model that like I can explain to
somebody how this model got this answer
like I'm I'm pretty much always going to
go with the explainability part and your
question is kind of like is like part of
the reason for that is like if I get a
question why did the model give me this
answer like I I'm I'm very happy to
explain to them and and then that could
sort of drive a conversation about like
the limitations of the model maybe that
would be an indication that you know
maybe it's time maybe this
model has exceeded its use utility and
we need to build an reestimate IT build
a new one that has other other risk
drivers in it you know those types of
things so it definitely happens we're
never really putting as position where
something goes out the door that sort of
came out of a model and nobody looked at
RM I see you have a question in the chat
as well if you want to ask this
next yeah hi thanks small question um if
I understand your organization correctly
I'm trying to understand whether you
consider yourself to be a embedded
within the business units or more of a
centralized operation for your data
science work yeah we're a centralized uh
sort of function a support function
um and then more on a project type basis
would we I consider ourselves like
embedded with a team so we'll you know
for if we're working on a project and we
need to have the subject matter experts
in the room like then then we'll sort of
in that way so on a project
basis maybe we would become embedded but
we're never truly embedded because you
know we don't run the models and and uh
we're we're not
really engaged in that rating process
like on the ground so much I saw one
thing always qualitate quantitative and
qualitative part of the model I maybe I
misspoke I meant like the the the rating
the rating process or the rating the
analysis is what I maybe should have
said I think we have time for a few more
questions here um but Alan I see you had
another question the chat want to jump
in
yeah sure um thanks um I'm curious Matt
um you you mentioned at one point having
things that sort of you want to do you
want to develop sort of products that
you want to develop and I'm curious what
the balance is of things like that where
you get to sort of be entrepreneurial
versus and that goes into some kind of
portfolio of prioritization that I think
a lot of us kind of familiar with
conceptually versus things that kind of
come into your team from the businesses
or from other customers how do you
balance those things what kind of help
do you have in in picking you know when
to do one versus the other yeah I mean
this is getting back to that idea of
like we employ some of the tools that uh
are available to technology so like we
have a you know a support mailbox that's
the quantitative modeling support
mailbox so if somebody has a a question
or something that they want us to work
on you know they send a they send an
email there it automatically creates a
jira ticket and and we manage we use
jira to sort of manage our work we do
maintain like workflow limits so we
don't really want people working on more
than two or three things at a time and
so far it's worked we really haven't had
this that sort of like uh um moment of
like oh do I do this really important
thing or that really important thing
we've kind of been able to use that to
help us not only like not forget to do
things which is a huge huge benefit but
like manage our workload uh but like it
also gets back to that like um idea of
like building trust so I've been lucky
that um you know I I I had the uh
opportunity to um sort of
uh do things that are sort of have that
overlap between stuff that my company
needs to get done and stuff that I'm
interested in doing so that's been
really good and it's been nice to sort
of be able to to um sort of call the
shots along the
way nice
thanks Jeffrey just put a question into
the chat how does your team work
together do you have a data engineer
that pulls data passes it the data
scientist um or does that the person
that creates the model do it all or
something
else yeah I mean it's really is on a
project by project basis that sort of
the the Genesis of what that data set
looks like um it sometimes sometimes the
team who's responsible for the rating
have some have access to like really
great data sets that we can use to build
our models sometimes it's about like uh
pulling it together uh from like public
uh publicly available sources like the
you know Federal Reserve economic
database or other types of things and
pulling that together I will say that
like I I did neglect to say we do have
embedded on our team like a uh folks who
are like that mlops type role so they're
more technologists who are helping us
like maintain our platform and also like
their crackerjack coders who could sort
of step in and give us some feedback on
how to do things how to get how to make
get work better and also how to like
engage with some of the internal
resources and technology so do have some
folks on the team who are more of that
technology role who are helping us get
things done and sometimes they'll be
they'll be useful in that sort of data
more The Upfront data
acquisition um I know we talked a little
bit about trust or came up a few times
and I was just wondering what are some
of those ways you were able to build
trust with the
stakeholders yeah I I'd say like early
on and it was I used the shiny app to
get it done right so early on I was this
was before when I was doing like the
model validation stuff so I kind of had
a I was starting to get insights into
like what are the sensitivities what are
driving this model how does this thing
actually work and I had just learned
shiny so I was like I took that
knowledge and I sort of built a shiny
app that allowed people to like move a
slider press the button see the graph
type of stuff and I would say that like
people's socks were knocked off they
were blown away so those types of
moments are like not just useful in for
because now they have something that
they can look at the at the sensitivity
but like from a more personal
perspective like suddenly people were
saying like oh Matt kind of seems to
know how to get things done maybe we
should trust him so I think it's like
looking for those types of opportunities
and it's never like a there's no
Playbook there it's just you had to kind
of keep your head head up and you got to
know your know what you're capable of
and and deliver and and that that's
really useful love it that's great um if
if people want to get connected with you
Matt is the best place LinkedIn yeah
LinkedIn is good LinkedIn is
good awesome um well I did just want to
remind everybody that um we did I think
this was probably five weeks ago now but
we had a lengthy conversation on how to
um estimate the ROI for a data project
and there was so many like thoughts on
this and conversations in the the chat
that we decided we want to have a a
separate follow-up conversation on that
um and so I shared that in the chat bit
earlier if anybody wants to add it to
their Calendar let me try and copy it
over
again um but that's going to be on
December 13 so it's on a Wednesday and
it's just like a bonus data science
hangout chat for us uh let me see here
it
is copy my message from above and put it
there but I'd love to have you all join
us on that if it's something that was of
interest to you when we talked about it
before feel free to add it to your
calendar but thank you so much Matt for
joining us thank you for hosting I
really enjoyed it thank you so much yeah
thank you well have a great rest of the
day uh we
actually think only have one more data
science hangout for
2023 so that will be next week before we
take our um holiday break for the
hangout so hope to see you all back next
week thanks everybody bye
bye